now protesters demanding political
reform in Lebanon had been given an
unexpected boost the head of the
Christian forces party Samir jaha has
asked his ministers to resign from the
government were crowds of demonstrators
celebrated announcement but they're
demanding deeper political change tens
of thousands have taken to the streets
across Lebanon since Thursday to protest
against tax increases and alleged
political corruption let's get the
latest now from Santa hora she's in the
Lebanese capital Beirut zina so last
night was the biggest protest we've seen
so far
what's this telling us about the
momentum of the demonstrations Dana a
four and protestors are back on the
streets you mentioned this afternoon
Saturday night's protests a very large
turnout not just in the Lebanese capital
but across the country and in many
cities across the country
the message these people are giving the
government is we will continue to demand
the resignation of the government we're
standing outside government palace
people here are defiant it is a message
to the prime minister side of Harini who
didn't resign on Friday but gave his
political partners up to Monday to come
up with a new budget plan that will not
involve taxing the poor or imposing new
taxes on gasoline but people say this is
not enough we don't trust the political
leadership anymore we want early
elections but this is easier said than
done this is a spontaneous protest
leaderless protests those in power have
been in power for decades they exploit
the state's resources that is how they
maintain support in the strike by
providing child so even if there is an
early election those people will have
access to the money
you know to to make sure that their
their hardcore supporters continue to
back them and while there are tens of
thousands in fact some people even say
hundreds of thousands in the street
there there is hundreds of thousands of
others who are still backing their
political the different political
parties in the country so this is not
going to be easy but people here are
hopeful whether that hope is well-placed
we have to wait and see yeah and zonah
the political fallout has already
started the head of the Lebanese Forces
party
samia's jaja announced that his
ministers would resign from the
government what impact is that likely to
have well the Lebanese Forces they have
four ministers and a 13 member cabinet
the cabinet will not topple and Saddam
Harini the Prime Minister has still not
approved that's accepted the resignation
now some here will say this is the
hypocritical move on the part of Shia
he's a part of the government and he's
part of the political establishment he
has been in power since the days of the
civil war people here are worried that
some politicians are going to ride the
wave of popular anger take advantage to
push their own agenda Joshua's agenda is
very clear he's opposed to hannity they
were allies in the past he's opposed
because howdini has been too
accommodating when the Hezbollah led
alliance in the country so the message
here what people want our leaders who
are loyal to Lebanon to the country not
to foreign powers who who do the bidding
of outside powers so that is why it is
so difficult to change the political
system in the country but there is no
doubt people here are going to keep the
pressure they're calling for a general
strike on Monday the association of
banks saying banks will remain closed on
Monday so this is going to really put
more pressure on the financial system
which really is on the brink of collapse
all right as a najara there in Beirut
zina thank you